y hemos invertido mucho tiempo pensando
en los mercados para los bienes y
servicios que las empresas producen
ahora hablaremos del mercado de los
factores de producción también conocido
como el mercado de factores cuáles son
los factores de producción ya hemos
hablado de ellos en varias ocasiones son
cosas como tierra trabajo capital y en
particular nos vamos a enfocar en este
vídeo en el trabajo aquí vemos unos ejes
donde el eje vertical está etiquetado
como salario que podemos ver como el
precio del trabajo por unidad de tiempo
y en el eje horizontal está la cantidad
de trabajo que es el número de
trabajadores en esa unidad de tiempo lo
que vamos a hacer del lado derecho es
pensar desde el punto de vista de una
empresa y del lado izquierdo vamos a
pensar desde el punto de vista del
mercado completo para comprender lo que
sucede desde el punto de vista de la
empresa podemos pensar en la demanda de
la empresa cuál es la ganancia que
obtiene la empresa cuando contrata a un
trabajador adicional para ello vamos a
pensar en algo llamado ingreso marginal
del producto el ingreso marginal del
producto suena algo
pero voy a poner aquí una tabla para que
podamos comprenderlo en términos
razonables digamos que este es el
trabajo y vamos a poner algunas columnas
aquí esta es cuánta producción puede
tener la empresa con base en las
unidades de trabajo luego tenemos el
producto marginal del trabajo cmt que se
refiere a cuánto más se puede producir
por cada unidad adicional de trabajo y
tendremos otras columnas aquí tenemos
cero unidades de trabajo una unidad de
trabajo y dos unidades de trabajo con
cero unidades solo podemos producir cero
unidades en ese periodo de tiempo cuando
tenemos un trabajador en una unidad de
tiempo se producen dos unidades cuando
tenemos al segundo trabajador ahora se
producen seis unidades si pensamos en el
producto marginal del trabajo el primer
trabajador puede producir dos unidades
adicionales pasamos de 0 a 2 pero al
agregar al segundo trabajador se
producen 4 unidades adicionales quizá
esto se deba a la especialización y
cosas por el estilo pero con el tiempo
quizá tengamos una disminución del
producto marginal del trabajo
pero si queremos pensar en cuál es la
ganancia real de la empresa no se trata
solamente de lo que se produce sino de
cuánto puede obtener la empresa de eso
podemos pensar en el ingreso marginal en
este caso digamos que es de 4 pesos son
4 pesos constantes y luego pensamos en
el ingreso marginal del producto que va
a ser igual al producto marginal del
trabajo multiplicado por la cantidad de
dinero o la cantidad de dinero adicional
por unidad de trabajo por lo que esto va
a ser 2 por 48 pesos una forma de pensar
en esto es que cuando la empresa pasa de
tener cero trabajadores a un trabajador
tiene ocho pesos de ingreso adicional
con base en lo que este trabajador puede
producir y cuando se agrega otro
trabajador tenemos cuatro por cuatro
igual a 16 unidades adicionales de
ingreso podemos graficar esto de la
siguiente manera como les comenté a
veces podemos tener al inicio el
beneficio de la especialización pero
conforme pasa el tiempo aparecen los
rendimientos decrecientes típicamente en
una clase de economía se dibuja una
recta con pendiente negativa
para hacerlo más sencillo pero el
ingreso marginal del producto de la
empresa se puede ver cómo la demanda
individual de trabajo de la empresa con
las primeras unidades de trabajo se
tiene un ingreso marginal del producto
bastante alto pero conforme pasa el
tiempo aparecen los rendimientos
decrecientes de agregar cada vez más
trabajadores al personal como se ve esto
en el mercado lo que podemos hacer es
sumar todos los ingresos marginales del
producto de todas las empresas en el
mercado y si las sumamos obtendremos la
curva de demanda del mercado de trabajo
si sumamos todas vamos a tener algo así
lo escribimos curva de demanda del
mercado de trabajo
ahora cuál será el nivel racional de la
cantidad de trabajo en el mercado para
responder a esto debemos pensar en la
curva de oferta del mercado de trabajo
vamos a enfocarnos primero en el mercado
e igual que en el mercado de la mayoría
de las cosas mientras mayor sea el
salario más personas querrán participar
en ese mercado de trabajo así que a un
sueldo menor pocas personas querrán
trabajar en esta industria pero conforme
aumentan los salarios más personas
querrán participar en este mercado de
trabajo
esta es la curva de oferta del mercado
de trabajo así que cuál será el precio
de equilibrio para el trabajo qué es el
salario es donde se intersectan las
curvas de la demanda y la oferta de
trabajo ya hemos visto esto varias veces
a esto le llamamos w asterisco y la
cantidad de equilibrio de trabajo es q
asterisco cómo va a impactar esto a la
empresa si suponemos que este es un
mercado de trabajo en competencia
perfecta vamos a suponer que esta
empresa no puede establecer el salario
va a tener que pagarle a sus
trabajadores lo que
de establecido como salario de
equilibrio por lo que esto va a ser lo
que se conoce como el costo marginal del
factor para la empresa el costo por
unidad adicional de trabajo es el
salario que tendrá que pagar suponemos
que podemos obtener toda la cantidad de
trabajadores que necesitemos porque
hablamos de un mercado de trabajo en
competencia perfecta en esta industria y
que aquí dibujo como una recta esto es
el costo marginal del factor y ya
podemos imaginar cuál será la cantidad
racional que esta empresa debe contratar
va a seguir contratando trabajadores
hasta que el ingreso adicional por
unidad de trabajo que se obtiene no sea
mayor al costo adicional de esa unidad
de trabajo qué es lo que sucede aquí
esto indica que la cantidad racional de
trabajo o q asterisco para la empresa
está aquí por el momento vamos a
detenernos aquí lo importante es darse
cuenta de que esto se parece a lo que ya
hemos visto al hablar de cosas como
ingreso marginal y costo marginal para
los bienes de una empresa pero aquí
hablamos de los insumos de una empresa
por lo que en lugar de tener las curvas
de ingreso marginal y el precio en un
mercado de competencia perfecta
que se define por el precio de
equilibrio aquí tenemos el costo de la
empresa que se define por el salario de
equilibrio en el mercado